[Music]
kim kardashian and pete davidson attend
their first red carpet event as a couple
i'm very happy and very content
and it's such a good feeling while scott
disick makes his red carpet debut with
rebecca donaldson and kravis well you
know what they do pda people on thursday
night the 41 year old reality star
arrived at the la premiere of her famous
family's new hulu series the kardashians
with her boyfriend on her arm kim
looking fab in a skintight silver terry
mcglare gown and matching choker
necklace pete in shades a black suit
white t-shirt and sneakers i love that
the kkw beauty founder walked the red
carpet solo but an eyewitness tells et
the two arrived together and while kim
posed for picks pete walked behind the
carpet and waited for her seeming very
chill and animated while chatting with
kim's pals quote pete looked towards the
carpet while kim was walking and being
interviewed and he looked like he was
proud of her at the end of the day life
is about being happy
being who you are inside the event the
eyewitness says kim looked so happy to
be there with pete adding that the 28
year old comedian was making her laugh
in their seats
yep following the screening et's
eyewitness says kim posed for solo pics
while pete held his own talking to
different people quote pete was very
supportive of kim and making sure she
was taken care of but also let her do
her thing and he did his and get this
according to the eyewitness kim and pete
left the event together hugging and
holding hands as a camera crew followed
them it's really lit and fun and crazy
now we know pete won't appear on camera
in the first season of the kardashians
new show but kim will dish on their love
this is a relationship that i don't
think anybody saw coming from who are
you texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet the reality star previously told
variety that while they hadn't filmed
together yet she's not opposed to it
adding quote i think i might film
something really exciting coming but it
wouldn't be for this season well season
one hasn't even aired yet and i'm
already ready for season two i don't
know how you're gonna top that but kim
wasn't the only one flaunting her
relationship scott disick and his lady
love rebecca donaldson made their
romance red carpet official scott
looking dapper in a black suit and white
dress shirt while the 27 year old model
rocked a one-shoulder gray dress with
heels and a clutch of course scott's ex
kourtney kardashian attended the event
with her fiance travis barker but an
eyewitness tells et the exes didn't
mingle and while the 42 year old pooch
founder and the 46 year old blink 182
drummer are trying to expand their
family put the sample in this cup
we'll take our mics off you know get the
audio a source recently told et that
scott who shares three kids with court
isn't fond of the idea quote scott
doesn't like the idea of courtney and
travis growing their family but the rest
of the family is very supportive and
that family was right there by their
sides on premiere night
check out travis's kids 16 year old
alabama and 18 year old landon posing it
up on the red carpet alongside travis's
stepdaughter 23 year old atiana de la
hoya of course they're the kids the
rocker shares with his ex-wife shayna
mookler um i won't be tuning in
however
um you know i think it's fine if you
know this is an opportunity that they
want to be a part of and you know my
main concern is always you know my
children are my first priority and you
know that's one thing that you know
travis and i you know do agree on our
children come first and their happiness
and as long as you know the kardashians
are good to my kids you know that's all
that matters to me as a mom as for
quartz kids twelve-year-old mason and
nine-year-old penelope they didn't go
but six-year-old rain was there we were
told he was cracking jokes and making
everyone laugh
[Music]